[Música]
el ministro de petróleos de Venezuela
haré que laissami renunció a su cargo
luego de que su entorno cercano se viera
involucrado en un escándalo de presunta
corrupción dentro de la estatal
petrolera pedevesa la oposición expresó
su desconfianza ante la investigación
que realizará el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
ordenó levantar el alto el fuego con el
grupo criminal denominado clan del Golfo
una de las mayores organizaciones
ligadas al narcotráfico en el país que
recientemente realizó un nuevo ataque
contra integrantes de la fuerza pública
el gigante tecnológico Amazon anunció un
nuevo recorte estado desde nueve mil
puestos de trabajo según la compañía se
trata de una medida necesaria y que
beneficiará a la empresa en el futuro en
los últimos meses ya fueron despedidas
18.000 personas de Amazon
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Venezuela porque hasta ahora ministro de
petróleo ostaré que la isaami renunció a
su cargo luego de que su entorno se
viera implicado en presuntos actos de
corrupción que el gobierno está
investigando parte de ellos dentro de la
estatal pedevesa se trata de una de las
figuras fuertes del chavismo que fue
vicepresidente del país con Nicolás
maduro y canciller durante el gobierno
de Hugo Chávez el fin de semana se
produjeron otras renuncias y detenciones
por las mismas investigaciones de
corrupción Daniela Zambrano corresponsal
de France 24 en Venezuela nos explicó
Cuáles han sido las reacciones a lo que
él aissamica como una Cruzada de maduro
contra la corrupción
se pronunció el vicepresidente del
partido socialista Unido de Venezuela
diosdado cabello respaldando estas
acciones se pronunció el fiscal general
diciendo que en las próximas horas va a
haber más detenciones y que fue oportuno
y era lo que debía ser el ministro de
petróleo estaría que la isami de poner
su cargo a la orden recordemos que se
está hablando de que se habrían perdido
más de tres mil millones de dólares por
concepto de la venta de crudo y esto
sería la razón principal de estas
detenciones pero también como lo decía
se han pronunciado dirigentes de la
oposición en el caso de Enrique capriles
decía a través de la red social Twitter
no se trata de un acto de Justicia sino
un ajuste de cuentas entre la cúpula que
detenga el poder se están peleando por
el botín también se pronunciaba Juan
guaidó decía que el régimen de maduro
confirma lo que todos los venezolanos
sabían son los responsables de
emergencia de la emergencia humanitaria
y de desfalcar a la nación recordemos
que estas denuncias
corrupción se anuncian en momentos en
los que hay numerosas protestas en el
país sobre todos los sectores de
trabajadores públicos que han reclamado
aumentos salarial y la respuesta del
gobierno ha sido que no hay dinero para
ello y se conoce este escándalo además
de tres mil millones de dólares que no
se sabría dónde estarían y por eso se
detienen a los principales funcionarios
de la industria petrolera de pedevesa el
gobierno de Colombia liderado por el
presidente Gustavo Petro anunció El Fin
Del cese al fuego pactado con el grupo
al margen de la ley denominado clan del
Golfo se trata de uno de los mayores
grupos ligados a la Industria del
narcotráfico que recientemente instó un
paro por parte de los mineros en el
noroeste de Colombia aéreo a integrantes
de la policía
la paz total en Colombia está un poco
más lejos tras el anuncio del fin del
cese al fuego con el grupo criminal más
grande del país el clan del Golfo
he ordenado a la fuerza pública
reactivar todas las operaciones
militares contra el clan del Golfo se
suspende el cese bilateral con este
grupo al margen de la ley no
permitiremos que sigan sembrando zozobra
y terror en las comunidades la razón un
supuesto ataque con fusil del grupo
criminal contra la policía Aunque el fin
de La tregua comenzó antes en la región
del bajo cauca en el Noroeste del país
que vive un paro minero desde el 2 de
marzo presuntamente instigado por el
clan del Golfo para beneficiarse de las
rutas de narcotráfico según acusa el
gobierno colombiano tras el anuncio la
organización ilegal no tardó en
responder e incendió varios vehículos en
la región o como advertencia
situaciones como las ocurridas el día de
hoy en la que vehículos por fuera de
caravanas fueron incendiados
no pueden repetirse rechazamos
con toda contundencia los actos de
violencia que se han venido presentando
en el bajo cauca antioqueño
fundamentalmente el ejecutivo ya había
acusado al clan del Golfo por no
respetar el armisticio y seguir
Traficando con cocaína y oro en la
región este movimiento es además una
advertencia para los otros dos grupos
con los que el gobierno está negociando
la paz el eln y las disidencias de las
farcp y el mensaje es claro cualquier
conversación de paz puede quebrarse si
no se respetan a sus términos por
tercera semana consecutivas centenares
de maestros marcharon por las calles de
la paz en Bolivia los profesores
demandan la incorporación de más
maestros en las escuelas públicas y un
aumento en el presupuesto para el área
de Educación Así mismo rechazan el nuevo
plan de estudios que fue presentado por
el gobierno que también hace frente a un
creciente descontento que ha provocado
manifestaciones en su contra por parte
de diferentes sectores sociales
económicos y políticos
y vamos a Chile porque el Banco Central
de ese país presentó las cifras donde se
muestra que el pib creció menos de lo
previsto Aunque esquivo Por poco un
escenario de recesión económica para
ampliar esta información me acompaña en
el estudio mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge bienvenido Así es bueno el pib
chileno creció un 0,1% en el cuarto
trimestre Respecto a los últimos tres
meses anteriores pero eso sí rompió una
racha de tres caídas intermetriales para
registrar un crecimiento del dos coma
cuatro por ciento en el conjunto del
2022 esto según datos del Banco Central
de ese país los datos muestran que es
economía se está estabilizando pese a
las subidas a los tipos de interés las
más altas en más de dos décadas que
buscan frenar la inflación el gobierno
Espera que el producto interno bruto
sufra una contracción este año por la
caída de la inversión y la demanda chile
sería una de las pocas economías de
América Latina de las que se espera una
caída del pib en 2023 pero un nuevo
elemento externo
en escena las turbulencias en el sector
financiero global sobre este tema le
preguntamos a Mario Marcel ministro de
hacienda de chile en el caso de chile el
impacto
que más ha sentido tiene que ver con la
calidad de los precios de las materias
primas incluyendo el cobre eso ha
contribuido a devaluar en el margen
nuestra moneda respecto del dólar pero
el sistema financiero chileno en
relación a las antiguas situaciones que
hemos visto es considerablemente más
sólido Dado que los requerimientos de
capital de basilea tres ya están en
aplicación en Chile desde hace tres o
cuatro años atrás y se aplican a todas
las instituciones financieras de modo
que
los temas más bien tienen que ver con el
impacto indirecto que esto puede tener
que no tiene por qué ser menor puede ser
significativo como ha sido en otras
oportunidades Jorge Pues a usted muchas
gracias por esta ampliación nosotros
seguimos con noticias económicas porque
las directivas de Amazon anunciaron el
recorte de 9.000 empleos Durante los
próximos meses debido a la incertidumbre
económica actual argumentaron que es una
decisión que beneficiará a la compañía
en el futuro esta medida se suma otro
despido masivo que dejó a 18.000
personas sin empleo Durante los últimos
meses veamos más en el informe de Andrés
triviño
Amazon anunciaba una nueva Ronda de
despidos masivos a empleados así lo dio
a conocer mediante un comunicado Andy
yasi director general de la compañía
Durante las próximas semanas 9000
trabajadores se verán afectados
sumándose a los despidos que comenzaron
en noviembre del año pasado y que se
extendieron hasta enero dejando sin
empleo a un total de 27.000 personas
durante varios años previos a este la
mayoría de nuestros negocios agregaron
una cantidad significativa de empleados
sin embargo dada la incertidumbre
económica en la que vivimos y la
incertidumbre que existe en el futuro
cercano hemos optado por ser más
eficientes en nuestros costos y personal
ya así aseguró que las áreas que se
verán más afectadas serán los servicios
web el reclutamiento humano publicidad y
la aplicación de streaming Twitch la
cual no ha dado los resultados esperados
a la compañía Igualmente aseguró que
durante la pandemia se crearon nuevos
empleos que ahora ya no son necesarios
Porque el repunte de la demanda cayó a
medida que se relajaron las
restricciones Por lo cual se produce el
anuncio Amazon es la segunda empresa con
mayor número de empleados de Estados
Unidos con 1.5 millones de trabajadores
solamente por detrás de los
supermercados Walmart así el gigante del
comercio electrónico se suma a otras
empresas tecnológicas como Microsoft y
meta la matriz de Facebook la cual dijo
que eliminaría 10.000 empleos este año
luego de acabar con 11.000 puestos en
total el sector tecnológico ha despedido
a más de 200.000 personas Amazon ha
dicho que sus ganancias operativas
Pueden seguir cayendo en los próximos
meses debido a las condiciones
económicas a nivel global mientras que
sus acciones cayeron un 1.4% luego del
anuncio
así llegamos al final de este
informativo ustedes Gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]